I thought at the minute he entered the
business that jay-z would be a
formidable presence in the Aegean
industry he is a draw and I've heard
from the agent community that they're
worried certainly from our competitors
standpoint they've got to be concerned
jay-z and rock nation bring a lot to the
party he's got reached to places that
probably are different than what
typically CAA is involved in it comes
down to two things the ability to
recruit players and the ability to
deliver the contract as a recruiter I'd
give him an A+ he's done a pretty superb
job of picking players that can trigger
multiple revenue streams they are good
for contract negotiations they are good
for endorsements they're good for
crossover entertainment projects got a
starting quarterback of a New York
football team Durant is there for
marketing the CC he's got a starting
pitcher for the New York Yankees it
doesn't get a whole lot better than that
terms of negotiating I don't think he
negotiates the contract with guys who
are well-established and experienced in
the business backing him up there's no
limited as to what he can do I am
confident that there are more players
recruiting jay-z than vice-versa
are they over selling I'm going to get
to know soar getting moved movies or
music perhaps but there's an entree
there that can be used my sense is they
won't change the business uh-huh
they'll make an impact one of the
earliest pieces of advice I ever got in
this business was from Dean Smith it was
not to worry about your competition is
about his rivalry with Duke he said he
never focused on that it was just about
you know doing what he thought was right
for North Carolina and that's how I view
our business
you